how do you guys know each other
work where
I knew it was a hospital I knew
it was a hospital you know how I knew
not the Indians it was the one black
girl that let me know as a hospital what
are you immigrant kid I told you I
knew it I knew it was immigrants
kids and you're all doctors and none of
you want to be I knew that the second I
saw this black girl randomly hanging out
with eight Indians I was like that's the
doctor for sure no other reason you guys
would be friends you see eight Indians
it could be anything you know I mean
doctor
engineer that's about it but
you see one random other minority that's
a that's a group of doctors
right look at these not a doctor in the
bunch I know it
you think all Indians are smart you
haven't met this Punjabi table right
here what Hood little do you guys
do
criminals these people look at this guy
straight out of a 90s rap video
who dressed you fat Joe hello
what's up
gray hair a do-ragon a steady nine to
five none of these things belong
together unbelievable
this is the choice you made it was the
do-rag
what about you how do you know this guy
that's your brother I could tell your
little brother right
yeah you're like his hype man I feel it
what do you do for a living besides
trying to look as Italian as possible
huh you work in finance who the
gives their money to you
nothing about you seems trustworthy with
money you put money into it when people
give money to you what do you suggest
crypto I bet
you guys in relationships
you're married to an Italian I did not
tell you this looked
Italian I was right I saw the black girl
knew she was a doctor I saw this guy I
knew he had no clue he was
thank you
who are you married to that lets you go
out of the house like this
that makes sense there we go
I should have known
how are you buddy you're
adorable
son if I was gay I'd you for sure
you're the kind of guy I always settled
down with you know what I mean I trust
you you have a trustworthy face what do
you do for a living
insurance I bet you do a dog you're the
safest bet in this hey you
know what else is Insurance you what's
your ethnicities I'm very confused by
this Dominican whoa light-skinned
Dominican I bet you're just swimming in
Dominican business huh that's another
sociology less Anglo features are very
desirable in uh like minority
communities right like light skin I have
green eyes from my imperialism
nobody cares how it happened it's crazy
I used to ask my parents about
getting ice from and they'd be like
uh your great grandma talking for the
team okay
that's what this is
[Music]